ما الملفت بالنسبه لك سواء في توقيت او
تفاصيل تحقيق
الجيش الملف كثير جدا هنا وال غير المكشوف
عنه اكثر من المكشوف في واقع الامر
والسؤال المركزي الذي يعني يثيرني هنا
حينما قرات الخبر واقراه في صحف عده يعني
من هار الى معريف الى يديعوت الى وين كل
المواقع عمليا هنالك سؤال مهم الذي يتحدث
الان والذي تحدث الان ليس الناطق العسكري
الناطق العسكري تحدث ليله الامس وقال
هنالك ثلاثه وذكر اسمائهم ولكن الان
التحقيق الاولي هذا يذكر انه هذا التحقيق
الاولي يتم يعني اجراءه بوجود رئيس اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي طبعا واضح لانه قضيه
هامه جدا ولكن من صرب الخبر انه هنالك
تحقيق اولي وهنالك
نتائج اوليه من سرب هذا الخبر الى الاعلام
الاسرائيلي الان واضح انه ليس المتحدث
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي هنالك من صرب وهناك
اذاما تقرا الاخبار جميعها الان انت تجد
بانه هنالك خبر بانه قائد كبير في الجيش
يقول كذا وكذا دون ذكر اسماء هذا يقودني
الى استنتاج مهم الان في هذه المرحله انه
يوجد خلاف حقيقي في قياده الجيش
الاسرائيلي
من اجل الضغط على القياده السياسيه وخاصه
على جرنت لفتح باب المفاوضات لتحرير
الاسرى يعني تسريب الخبر الكامل بالتحقيق
الاولي لم ياتي من طرف الجيش انما جاء من
طرف ما في الجيش لا نعرف من هو ح حتى وان
كان تحقيقا اوليا لكن الجيش لم يعلن عنه
بعد من اعلن هو الصحافه الاسرائيليه
بواسطه اسماء مختلفه يعني بدون ذكر اسماء
لقاءد كبير في الجيش والان ما حصل مثل ما
تحدثت مراسلتكم السيده انه اجتماع جران في
مقر وزاره الدفاع في يوم السبت اللي هو
يوم مقدس عند اليهود ولا يكون في الا في
ظروف طارئه هذا الاجتماع يدل على انه جلنت
يفهم الان واضحا بانه اسهمه بدات يعني بال
بالتراجع هذه من ناحيه الاسهم السياسيه
اثنين زياده عتم الثقه به شخصيا
وبقيادة الخبر والاسماء والى اخره يعني
يثير الشك لماذا لانه اعتقادي هنالك قوه
ضغط في داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي لا توافق
على كل الخطط الاسرائيليه الحربيه وتريد
ان تفتح باب مفاوضات من
اجل الافراج عن الاسرى هذا الموقع الموقف
الذي نحن به وهذا انا اعتقد دلائل
السياسيه لما حدث في ليله البارحه ليس فقط
انه الجيش الان متخبط وفي ارتباك و يعني
تفاصيل الحادث كما ترويها
الصحافه يعني مثيره جدا للاهتمام انه ما
جعلهم في النهايه يشكون لماذا انه هؤلاء
قد يكونوا اسرا لانه واحد من الاصر هو
جنجي ابيض يعني
اه و وكانوا كلهم خرجوا دون قمصان يعني
اجسامهم عاريه اي وهذا ما اثار ان ممكن
انه يكون حصل خطا ولكن حتى لما حصل الخطا
هذا ال هنالك من استغل هذه الحادثه من من
اجل ان يقدم الاجنده السياسيه بالضغط على
الجيش والقياده العسكريه من اجل فتح
مفاوضات من اجل تحرير الاسرى وهذا ما نحن
بصدده الان وهذا هو الاجتماع الذي يعقد
الان في
وزاره الحرب الاسرائيليه في تلفيف مقابل
يعني الى امام او يعني في الجهه المقابله
يوجد عائلات الاسرى يقفون هناك ويتظاهرون
وشعارهم المهم والجديد جدا جدا هو الان
الان الان يعني وقف الحرب الان وفتح
المفاوضات الان هذا ضغط جديد وهم قالوا
يعني في اجتماع الليله البارحه عائلات
الاسرى انه يجب تصعيد المعركه امام
القياده السياسيه لانه حتى الان على ما
يبدو انه يعني تعاملوا بكفوف الناعمه
والان هذه العائلات فهمت ومن والمفكرين
الاستراتيجيين الذين يعملون معهم
ويساعدونهم بانه يجب تصعيد الموقف كيف
سيكون الت كيف سيكون يعني لو تحدثنا عن
الحراك كيف سيتصاعد
الحراك نعم اولا انا باعتقادي انه هذه
الليله سنرى يعني ليس فقط عشرات الالاف
يتظاهرون
امام رسه وزاره الدفاع وال يعني مكاتب
الحكومه في تلبير ولكن سنرى اكثر من ذلك
يعني انا ريايه تقدير نتحدث عن مئات
الالاف وهذه بدايه هامه اذا ما بدات هذه
المظاهرات كما بدات قبل الحرب ضد نتنياهو
سيكون لها يعني تاثير هام جدا على تغيير
الرؤيه الكامله للمجتمع الاسرائيلي المؤيد
للحرب انه يبدا في الانعطاف قد تكون هذه
الليله ليله الانعطاف التي الكثير يتحدث
عنها متى تاتي وقد يكون هذه هي الليله